Es ist der seltsamste Planet des Universums,
der bisher gefunden wurde, muss ich einschränken.
Dieser Exoplanet ist wirklich äußerst äußerst
merkwürdig: WASP-121b ist nicht nur so super-super-heiß;
er hat auch eine äußerst kuriose Form.
Er sieht nämlich aus wie ein American Football.
Und noch etwas lässt Astronomie-Teams weltweit
staunen: Der Exoplanet schleudert Metalle
ins All.
Dort gibt es Eisengas.
Total verrückt.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke, nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
herzlich willkommen!
- Der Exoplanet trägt die Katalognummer WASP-121b
und umkreist eine Sonne im Sternbild Achterdeck
am Südhimmel.
Er liegt rund 900 Lichtjahre von der Erde
entfernt und hat dreimal so viel Masse wie
Jupiter.
Und der ist ja der größte Planet in unserem
System.
Astronomie-Teams konnten WASP-121b bereits
vor vier Jahren (2015) aufspüren und eine
wirkliche Besonderheit beobachten: Der Exoplanet
ist nämlich äußerst kurios geformt.
Weil er seinen Heimatstern so eng umkreist,
wird er von dessen Gravitation fast zerissen.
Aber nur fast.
Seine Form jedenfalls wird extrem in die Länge
gestreckt und die Ähnlichkeit zu einem American
Football lässt sich keinesfalls abstreiten.
Doch das, was das US-Forschungsteam jetzt
nachweisen konnte, ist eine echte Premiere:
Mit Hilfe des Hubble-Weltraumteleskops konnten
die Fachleute nämlich beobachten, dass das
Exoplanet Metalle ins Weltall schleudert.
Konkret konnten mit dem “Space Telescope
Imaging Spectrograph” Wolken von Eisen-
und Magnesium-Gas um WASP-121b beobachtet
werden.
Die Analysen zeigen, dass die obere Atmosphäre
des Exoplaneten auf unglaubliche 2.500 Grad
Celsius aufgeheizt wird - bedingt durch seine
Nähe zum Stern.
WOW!
Solch eine hohe Temperatur konnte bislang
auf keinem anderen bekannten Exoplaneten nachgewiesen
werden.
WASP-121b wird in der Fachsprache auch als
sogenannter “Hot Jupiter” bezeichnet.
Damit sind Gasplaneten gemeint, deren Masse
ähnlich zu der des Jupiters ist (oder sogar
größer) und auf dessen Oberfläche es zudem
sehr heiß ist!
Diese extrem hohe Temperatur erklärt auch,
warum Metalle wie Magnesium oder Eisen als
Gas ins All geschleudert werden und nicht
in der Atmosphäre kondensieren.
Auf diesem Exoplaneten ist es also tatsächlich
so heiß, dass sogar Eisen verdampft und in
den Weltraum verschwindet.
Magnesium und Eisen kommen hier also in gasförmiger
Form vor und steigen in die obere Atmosphäre
auf.
Dort entweichen sie dann ins All - zusammen
mit Helium und Wasserstoff.
Bislang kannten Fachleute solche Metallgase
auch von anderen Planeten - allerdings nur
INNERHALB der Atmosphäre.
Eine absolut spannende Entdeckung also!
Dazu David Sing, der an der Studie beteiligt
war: "Schwermetalle wurden bereits auf anderen
Hot Jupiter gesehen, aber nur in der unteren
Atmosphäre.
Also weiß man nicht, ob sie entweichen oder
nicht.
Bei Wasp-121b haben wir Magnesium und Eisengas
so weit weg von dem Planeten beobachtet, dass
sie nicht mehr durch Schwerkraft gebunden
sind."
In Zukunft soll dieser außergewöhnliche
Exoplanet auch mit dem James-Webb-Weltraumteleskop
beobachtet werden.
So erhoffen sich Forschungsteams weltweit,
dass dann eine detaillierte Analyse aller
chemischen Elemente möglich wird.
Diese Erkenntnisse eine große Hilfe dabei
sein, die Bildung solcher “Hot Jupiter”
und Planeten-Systemen im Allgemeinen besser
zu verstehen.
Biomarker für Exoplaneten Wie finden wir
Exoplaneten, auf denen es Leben ghibt?
Superspannendes Thema von HyperraumTV. anklicken,
anschauen und HyperraumTV abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!